Pourtant, notre rôle est de les y préparer.
L'imprévisibilité est donc, je pense, extraordinaire.
La troisième chose est que nous sommes tous d'accord
sur le fait que les enfants ont des capacités impressionnantes --
leurs capacités d'innovation.
Je veux dire, hier soir, Sirena était merveilleuse, non ?
Rien qu'à l'observer.
Elle est exceptionnelle mais je pense qu'elle n'est pas, pour ainsi dire,
une exception parmi tous les enfants.
C'est une personne extrêmement dévouée qui a découvert son talent.
J'affirme que tous les enfants ont un talent formidable
que nous dilapidons impitoyablement.
Je veux donc parler d'éducation
et je veux parler de créativité.
Pour éduquer, j'affirme que la créativité est aussi cruciale que l'alphabétisation
et que nous devrions la traiter de la même manière.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
C'est tout, au passage. Merci beaucoup.
(Rires)
Bon, plus que 15 minutes.
« Alors, je suis né... »
(Rires)
J'ai entendu une super histoire que j'adore raconter
à propos d'une petite fille en cours de dessin.
A six ans, elle dessinait au fond de la salle
et l'institutrice disait qu'elle ne suivait presque jamais,
sauf pendant ce cours de dessin.
L'institutrice, fascinée, est venue lui demander : « Que dessines-tu ? »
La fille a répondu : « Je dessine Dieu. »
Son institutrice : « Mais personne ne sait à quoi ressemble Dieu. »
La fille a dit : « Ce sera bientôt le cas. »
(Rires)
(Fin des rires)
Quand mon fils avait quatre ans en Angleterre,
enfin, il avait quatre ans partout en fait.
(Rires)
En toute rigueur, où qu'il soit allé, il avait quatre ans cette année.
Il jouait la pièce de la Nativité. La connaissez-vous ?
(Rires)
C'est une histoire très, très connue.
Mel Gibson en a réalisé la suite.
(Rires)
« Nativité II »
James a reçu le rôle de Joseph et nous étions ravis.
Pour nous, c'était un rôle principal.
La salle était remplie de complices en T-shirt :
« James Robinson EST Joseph ! »
Il n'avait pas de réplique et c'était au moment où les rois mages arrivent.
Ils viennent offrir de l'or, de l'encens et de la myrrhe.
Voici ce qui est arrivé.
Nous étions assis et je pense que les scènes étaient dans le désordre
car nous leur avons demandé après coup :
« - Vous êtes sûrs ? - Oui pourquoi ? C'était pas bon ? »
C'était juste inversé.
Les trois garçons sont entrés avec des torchons sur la tête.
Ils ont posé les boîtes et le premier a dit : « Voici de l'or. »
Le deuxième a dit : « Voici de la myrrhe. »
Le troisième a dit : « On m'a dit d'apporter ça. »
(Rires)
(Fin des rires)
Dans chaque situation, les enfants tentent leur chance.
S'ils ne savent pas, ils essaient quelque chose.
N'est-ce pas ? Les enfants ne craignent pas d'avoir tort.
Je ne dis pas qu'avoir tort est la même chose qu'être créatif.
Ce que l'on sait, c'est que, sans être préparé à avoir tort,
on ne peut pas imaginer quelque chose d'original
si l'on est pas préparé à avoir tort.
Avant de devenir adulte, la plupart des enfants ont perdu cette capacité.
Ils ont désormais la phobie de l'erreur.
Nos entreprises sont ainsi gérées.
Nous stigmatisons les erreurs.
Et nous entretenons des systèmes d'éducation
où une erreur est la pire chose que l'on puisse faire.
Il en résulte que nous éduquons les gens
en dehors de leurs capacités créatives.
Picasso a une fois déclaré que tous les enfants naissaient artistes.
Le problème est de rester artiste en grandissant.
Je crois sincèrement que l'on ne grandit pas dans la créativité
mais en dehors de celle-ci.
Plutôt, l'éducation nous en fait sortir.
Pourquoi donc ?
Je vivais à Stratford-on-Avon il y a encore cinq ans.
Nous avons déménagé de Stratford à Los Angeles.
Imaginez à quel point cette transition fut facile.
(Rires)
Nous vivions en fait à Snitterfield,
juste à côté de Stratford,
qui est le lieu de naissance du père de Shakespeare.
Vous êtes surpris ? Je l'ai été.
On ne pense jamais que Shakespeare a un père, non ?
N'est-ce pas ?
Car on n'imagine pas Shakespeare enfant, n'est-ce pas ?
Shakespeare à sept ans ?
Je n'y ai jamais pensé.
Il a bien eu sept ans à un moment.
Quelqu'un lui a enseigné l'anglais.
(Rires)
Cela a dû être agaçant.
« Peut mieux faire. »
(Rires)
Pour l'envoyer dormir, son père dit : « Allez, au lit ! »
à William Shakespeare.
« Et pose ce crayon ! »
(Rires)
« Arrête de parler comme ça ! »
« C'est déroutant. »
(Rires)
Bref, nous avons déménagé de Stratford à Los Angeles
et je veux juste rapidement parler de la transition.
Mon fils ne voulait pas venir.
J'ai deux enfants ; il a 21 ans et ma fille, 16.
Il ne voulait pas aller à Los Angeles.
Cela lui plaisait mais il avait une petite amie en Angleterre.
C'était l'amour de sa vie, Sarah.
Il la connaissait depuis un mois.
(Rires)
Cela dit, ils avaient passé quatre années ensemble.
C'est beaucoup quand on a 16 ans.
Il était contrarié dans l'avion :
« Je ne trouverai jamais une fille comme Sarah. »
Cela nous arrangeait bien, franchement --
(Rires)
(Fin des rires)
car elle était la raison principale pour laquelle nous quittions le pays.
(Rires)
Quelque chose vous frappe en arrivant en Amérique
et en voyageant :
chaque système d'éducation de la Terre a la même hiérarchie des matières.
Tous, sans exception : on pense que ça diffère, mais non.
En haut, les mathématiques et les langues, puis les humanités
et en bas, les arts ; partout sur Terre.
Et dans pratiquement chaque système, il y a aussi une hiérarchie des arts.
A l'école, l'art et la musique sont plus importants
que le théâtre et la danse.
Aucun système d'éducation terrestre
n'enseigne quotidiennement la danse
de la même manière que les mathématiques, pourquoi ?
Pourquoi pas ?
Je pense que c'est important.
Les maths sont importantes et la danse aussi.
Les enfants dansent tout le temps, nous aussi.
Chacun a un corps, non ? Ai-je raté une conférence ?
(Rires)
Clairement, quand les enfants grandissent,
on commence par éduquer leur corps.
On se focalise ensuite sur la tête.
Et plutôt d'un côté.
Si un alien découvrait notre éducation
et disait « A quoi sert l'éducation ? »,
il faudrait répondre, si l'on regarde le résultat,
ceux qui réussissent,
qui font tout ce qui est demandé,
qui reçoivent les bons points, qui sont les vainqueurs ;
il faudrait répondre que le but de l'éducation publique
à travers le monde
est de produire des professeurs d'université.
N'est-ce pas ?
Ce sont eux qui terminent premiers.
J'ai été l'un d'entre eux, donc bon.
(Rires)
J'aime les professeurs d'université mais on ne devrait pas les considérer
comme étant au sommet de la réussite humaine.
Ils ne sont qu'une forme de vie.
Une forme de vie parmi d'autres -- mais ils sont intrigants.
Amicalement, les professeurs sont intrigants.
D'après ce que j'ai vu, en général, ils vivent dans leur tête.
Ils vivent là-haut et légèrement d'un côté.
Ils sont désincarnés, au sens littéral du terme.
Ils voient leur corps comme un moyen de transport pour leur tête.
(Rires)
N'est-ce pas ?
C'est une manière d'aller à une réunion.
(Rires)
Si vous voulez assister à des expériences extra-corporelles au fait,
participez à une conférence résidentielle d'universitaires seniors
et passez à la discothèque le dernier soir.
(Rires)
Là-bas, vous les verrez.
Des hommes et des femmes adultes en train de se tortiller hors du rythme.
(Rires)
En train d'attendre la fin avant de rentrer écrire un papier dessus.
Notre système d'éducation est basé sur les compétences théoriques.
Il y a une raison à cela.
Dans le monde, il n'y avait aucun système d'éducation public
avant le XIXème siècle.
Ils sont apparus pour répondre aux besoins de l'industrialisation.
La hiérarchie provient donc de deux idées.
D'abord, les matières importantes pour le travail sont en haut.
A l'école, vous avez probablement été doucement écarté de choses que vous aimiez
parce que vous n'auriez pas pu en faire votre métier.
C'est vrai ?
« Ne fais pas de musique, tu ne seras pas musicien ;
ne fais pas d'art, tu ne seras pas artiste. »
Conseil bénin mais profondément erroné.
Le monde entier est englouti par une révolution.
Deuxièmement, les compétences théoriques.
Elles dominent notre vision de l'intelligence
car les universités conçoivent le système à leur image.
Quand on y pense,
le système entier de l'éducation publique est un processus prolongé
d'entrée à l'université.
Ainsi, de nombreuses personnes
talentueuses, brillantes et créatives pensent qu'elles ne le sont pas,
car ce qu'elles réussissaient à l'école
n'était pas jugé important ou était stigmatisé.
On ne peut pas continuer sur cette voie.
Dans les 30 prochaines années, selon l'UNESCO,
dans le monde, il y aura plus de diplômés
que depuis le début de l'Histoire.
Plus de diplômés.
Cela résulte de tout ce dont on a parlé :
la technologie et ses effets sur le travail,
ainsi que la démographie et l'énorme explosion de la population.
Soudain, les diplômes n'ont plus aucune valeur.
N'est-ce pas ?
Quand j'étais étudiant, avec un diplôme, on avait un travail.
Si on n'avait pas de travail, c'est qu'on ne le voulait pas.
Et je ne le voulais pas, franchement.
(Rires)
Mais maintenant les enfants diplômés reviennent à la maison
pour jouer aux jeux vidéos
parce qu'un travail nécessite un master au lieu d'une licence,
et un doctorat pour l'autre.
C'est une inflation scolaire.
Elle indique que la structure de l'éducation se dérobe sous nos pieds.
Il faut radicalement repenser notre vision de l'intelligence.
Nous savons trois choses sur l'intelligence :
un, elle est diversifiée.
Nous pensons au monde grâce à tous nos sens.
On pense de manière visuelle, auditive et kinesthésique.
On pense de façon abstraite, en mouvements.
Deuxièmement, l'intelligence est dynamique.
Si l'on observe les interactions dans notre cerveau
comme dans les présentations d'hier,
l'intelligence est incroyablement interactive.
Le cerveau n'est pas divisé en compartiments.
En fait, la créativité --
que je définis comme étant le processus d'avoir des idées originales de valeur --
provient la plupart du temps
de l'interaction de manières interdisciplinaires de voir les choses.
A propos, il y a un tube nerveux qui joint les deux moitiés du cerveau,
le corpus callosum.
Il est plus épais chez la femme.
Après ce qu'a dit Helen hier,
voilà probablement pourquoi les femmes sont plus multitâches.
Car vous l'êtes, non ?
Il y a une tripotée d'études mais je le sais d'expérience.
Si ma femme cuisine un repas à la maison, ce qui est rare...
heureusement.
(Rires)
Non, elle a d'autres atouts.
Mais si elle cuisine, elle parle aussi au téléphone,
elle parle aux enfants, elle peint le plafond...
(Rires)
Une opération à cœur ouvert par-là.
Si moi je cuisine, la porte est fermée, les enfants sont dehors,
le téléphone est éteint,
si elle entre, cela me gêne.
Je dis : « Terry, s'il te plait, j'essaie de cuire un œuf ici. »
(Rires)
« Laisse-moi tranquille. »
D'ailleurs, connaissez-vous cette vieille question :
« Un arbre tombe dans la forêt et personne ne l'entend. Est-ce arrivé ? »
Vous en souvenez-vous ?
J'ai récemment vu un joli T-shirt qui disait :
« Si un homme donne son avis dans la forêt et qu'aucune femme ne l'entend,
a-t-il encore tort ? »
(Rires)
(Fin des rires)
La troisième chose sur l'intelligence :
elle est profonde.
J'écris un nouveau livre appelé « L’Élément »,
qui est basé sur une série d'interviews de personnes
sur la découverte de leur talent.
Je suis fasciné par cela.
J'ai été stimulé en parlant à une femme géniale
que peu de gens connaissent : Gillian Lynne.
La connaissez-vous ? Quelques-uns.
Elle est chorégraphe et vous connaissez ses œuvres :
« Cats » et « Le Fantôme de l'Opéra ».
Elle est géniale.
J'ai été dans le comité du Royal Ballet, voyez-vous.
(Rires)
Gillian et moi déjeunions et j'ai dit : « Comment es-tu devenue danseuse ? »
A l'école, elle n'y arrivait pas.
Et l'école, dans les années 30, a écrit à ses parents :
« Nous pensons que Gillian a un trouble d'apprentissage. »
Elle ne tenait pas en place.
Aujourd'hui, ce serait de l'hyperactivité.
N'est-ce pas ?
Mais dans les années 30, l'hyperactivité n'avait pas encore été inventée.
Ce n'était pas une maladie disponible.
(Rires)
Les gens ne savaient pas qu'ils pouvaient avoir ça.
Bref, elle est allée voir un spécialiste.
Dans une pièce lambrissée de chêne, elle était avec sa mère
et on l'a faite asseoir sur une chaise au fond
où elle s'est tourné les pouces pendant 20 minutes
alors que l'homme parlait à sa mère
des problèmes que Gillian avait à l'école,
car elle dérangeait les autres, elle ne faisait pas ses devoirs etc...
Au bout du compte, le docteur s'est assis à côté de Gillian et a dit :
« J'ai écouté tout ce que m'a dit ta mère.
Je dois lui parler en privé.
Attend ici, on revient. Ce ne sera pas long. »
Et ils l'ont laissée.
Mais en sortant de la salle,
il a allumé la radio qui était sur son bureau.
Après être sortis de la pièce,
il a dit à la mère : « Observez-la. »
Dès qu'ils sont sortis de la salle,
elle était débout, en train de danser sur la musique.
Ils l'ont regardée quelques minutes et il s'est tourné vers la mère :
« Madame Lynne, Gillian n'est pas malade.
C'est une danseuse.
Amenez-la à une école de danse. »
Gillian m'a dit : « Ma mère l'a fait. C'était on ne peut plus formidable.
Nous sommes arrivés dans la salle remplie de gens comme moi,
qui ne pouvaient pas rester immobiles,
des gens qui devaient bouger pour penser. »
Bouger pour penser.
Ils ont fait du ballet, des claquettes, du jazz, du moderne, du contemporain.
Elle a enfin été auditionnée pour la Royal Ballet School.
Elle est devenue soliste et a eu une belle carrière au Royal Ballet.
Elle a été diplômée de la Royal Ballet School,
a fondé la Gillian Lynne Dance Company
et a rencontré Andrew Lloyd Webber.
Elle est derrière certaines des meilleures comédies musicales de l'Histoire.
Elle a réjoui des millions de personnes et elle est multimillionnaire.
Quelqu'un d'autre aurait pu lui donner des médicaments et lui dire de se calmer.
(Applaudissements)
(Fin des applaudissements)
Tout cela pour dire :
l'autre soir, Al Gore a parlé
d'écologie et de la révolution déclenchée par Rachel Carson.
A l'avenir, je crois que notre seul espoir
est d'adopter une nouvelle conception de l'écologie humaine,
dans le but de repenser notre vision de la richesse des capacités humaines.
Notre système éducatif a miné notre esprit
de la même façon que l'on extrait les ressources du sol terrestre.
A l'avenir, cela ne servira plus à rien.
Nous devons réinventer les principes fondamentaux
de l'éducation de nos enfants.
Voici une belle citation de Jonas Salk :
« Si tous les insectes disparaissaient de la surface de la Terre,
en 50 ans, toute la vie s'éteindrait.
Si tous les humains disparaissaient de la surface de la Terre,
en 50 ans, toutes les formes de vie prospéreraient sur Terre. »
Il a raison.
Ce que TED glorifie, c'est le don de l'imagination humaine.
Nous devons être prudents et utiliser ce don sagement
afin d'éviter certains des scénarios dont on a parlé.
La seule manière pour cela est d'apprécier les capacités créatives
pour la richesse qu'elles représentent
et d'apprécier nos enfants pour l'espoir qu'ils représentent.
Notre tâche est d'éduquer tout leur être afin qu'ils affrontent leur futur.
Au fait, on ne verra peut-être pas ce futur, mais eux, oui.
Notre mission est de leur permettre d'en faire quelque chose.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)